bundestags präsidentin wolfgang schäuble
ankündigt er wird eine der beiden
gedenkreden halten in der kommenden
halben stunde neben spd fraktionschef
rolf mützenich und zunächst also eine
gedenk minute für den verstorbenen so
sieht es zumindest aus und da kommt der
bundestagspräsident die abgeordneten
erheben sich hinter ihm rolf mützenich
der fraktionschef der spd einer der
beiden redner der tod von thomas
oppermann hat ja quer durch alle
parteien für große bestürzung gesorgt
der bundespräsident würdigte ihn als
großartigen menschen und überzeugten
demokraten nun also würdigen die
abgeordneten thomas oppermann der seit
2005 dem deutschen bundestag angehörte
zuletzt in der funktion als
bundestags-vizepräsident und nun also
beginnt diese trauerfeier
musikalisch umrahmt
[Musik]
sehr geehrte frau kirchhoff liebe
familienangehörige herr bundespräsident
gauck
liebe kolleginnen und kollegen verehrte
trauergäste wir trauern mit thomas
oppermann
unsere langjährigen kollegen und
vizepräsident des deutschen bundestags
er ist am vergangenen sonntag völlig
überraschend gestorben
im alter von nur 66 jahren
es berührt uns sehr dass sie sehr
gefragt kirchhoff zusammen mit drei
kindern des verstorbenen heute unter uns
sind
nicht zum plötzlichen tod thomas
oppermann hat uns wie viele menschen im
land tief getroffen ihnen der familie
allen angehörigen spreche ich mein tief
empfunden haben wir auch im namen des
ganzen solcher bundestags die große
anteile über partei und fraktionsgrenzen
hinweg zeigt die hohe wertschätzung die
thomas oppermann als mensch und als
politiker genoss vor drei wochen in
seiner letzten rede vor dem deutschen
bundestag was wir damals alle nicht
wussten das ist seine letzte rede war
sagte thomas oppermann
das vertrauen ist das wertvollste
kapital der parlamentarischen demokratie
und ich finde wir sollten einen
pfleglichen umgang damit sicherstellen
und für dieses wertvollste kapital der
parlamentarischen demokratie hat sich
thomas oppermann mit großer leidenschaft
eingesetzt
vertrauen so hat er es verstanden wächst
durch sacharbeit
für ihn war klar wie er selbst sagte das
praktische politische arbeit die
gesellschaft positiv verändern kann
nicht mehr und nicht weniger wollte er
der wunsch nicht als beobachter an der
seitenlinie zu verharren sondern die
gesellschaft aktiv mitzugestalten der
entsprang seinen erfahrungen während
eines zweijährigen
freiwilligendienstes bei der aktion
sühnezeichen mitte der 19
mitte der siebziger jahre im vergangenen
jahrhundert in den vereinigten staaten
von amerika er hat diese zeit als die
prägendste seines lebens bezeichnet das
zeigte sich auch in seinem einsatz für
die transatlantischen beziehungen
zurück in deutschland startete er in
studium von germanistik und anglistik in
tübingen auf jura endgültigen einem
damals wie heute besonders politisierten
studentische biotop und dort fand auch
zur sozialdemokratie politik in theorie
und praxis wie sie nicht mehr los was
seine prädikat ich sagen aber diese
thomas oppermann zunächst als richter an
den verwaltungsgerichten in hannover und
braunschweig und als rechts sitzend in
hannoversch münden
1990 wurde in den niedersächsischen
landtag bis zu seinem plötzlichen tod
war parlamentarier 30 jahre aus
überzeugung mit selbstbewusstsein und
mit erkennbarer freude an der
politischen arbeit unter dem damaligen
ministerpräsidenten spätere
bundeskanzler gerhard schröder den ich
auf der ehrentribüne begrüßen wurde er
1998 niedersächsischer wissenschafts und
bildungsminister und in hannover zeigte
thomas oppermann
seine qualitäten als
durchsetzungsstarker macher mit
rhetorischer kraft und mit der gabe
scharfsinnig und scharfzüngig politische
botschaften
vermitteln er sitzt er als
landesminister die idee der
stiftungsuniversität um ein
quantensprung in der
wissenschaftspolitik wie er sagte unter
seiner regie für den niedersachsen
intensiv studiengänge für bildungseliten
ein bundesweites novum und zum verdruss
nicht weniger in der eigenen partei
kämpfen thomas obermann auch für
studiengebühren
er war nie
ein parteisoldat und er sagte selbst
übersicht
ich bin oft gegen den strom geschwommen
so haben wir noch im deutschen bundestag
erlebt den wir seit 2005 angehört klar
und loyal und seiner
sozialdemokratischen haltung aber die
ideologisch streitbare in der sache doch
kompromissfähig wenn es galt
pragmatische lösungen zu finden
montiert und schlagfertigen der
politischen auseinandersetzung und
herzlich im zwischenmenschlichen umgang
er beherrschte die abteilung attacke
er beherrschte auch das mühsame
verhandeln und es braucht beides in der
parlamentarischen demokratie
er hat sein günstiger wahlkreis viermal
in folge direkt gewonnen
die wählerinnen und wähler thomas
oppermann stets ihr vertrauen eben das
wichtigste kapital in der demokratie im
bundestag hatte sich als obmann seiner
fraktion im geheimdienst
untersuchungsausschuss schnell einen
namen gemacht und bereits nach zwei
jahren wurde thomas oppermann zum ersten
parlamentarischen geschäftsführer der
spd gewählt
eine schlüsselposition in der die
interfraktionelle zusammenarbeit in der
schwierigen zeit der finanz-
wirtschafts- und euro-krise
mitgestaltete und ab 23 10 führte er die
spd fraktion damals fragte eine zeitung
kann es sein dass ein sozialdemokrat
erst dazu überredet werden muss in die
fußstapfen von kurt schumacher ihre
fritz erbe helmut schmidt und herbert
wehner zu treten
thomas oppermann ließ sich überreden und
er zeigte in der folge dieser
verantwortungsvollen position
führungsqualitäten und sms geschickt
das sind aber gelang über alle politisch
trennen denn das gemeinsame anliegen der
demokraten immer im blick zu behalten
das bewies auch seine wahl zum
vizepräsident des bundestags vor drei
jahren
sie war ausdruck der hohen wertschätzung
die er unter den abgeordneten über die
fraktionsgrenzen hinweg als kollege
genutzt
seine bemerkenswerte fähigkeit
ausgleichend zu wirken und brücken
zwischen unterschiedlichen auffassungen
und interesse zu bauen wurde in dieser
funktion einer breiteren öffentlichkeit
erst richtig bewusst
auch der feine humor und die
selbststeuerung die die ihn
auszeichneten
so haben meine kolleginnen und kollegen
und ich ihn im präsidium erlebt und
seine besonnene art sein sachverstand
seine kollegialität werden uns
schmerzlich fehlen
dass thomas auch wenn man zwar auf
ausgleich bedacht war aber immer auch am
ende von beratungen zu einem ergebnis zu
kommen
das bewiesen und seiner tätigkeit als
vorsitzender rechtsstellungskommission
des ältestenrats diese aufgabe die nicht
öffentlich wirksam aber für alle
rechtlichen fragen das mandat von großer
bedeutung ist hat er gerne und überaus
engagiert wahrgenommen und die
rechtsstellungskommission trat weit
häufiger als in der vergangenheit
in den letzten jahren zusammen als
vizepräsident des bundestags setzte sich
thomas oppermann nachdrücklich für eine
grundlegende wahlrechtsreform eine er
bezeichnete es in einer zeit in der die
demokratie ohnehin unter druck stände
als ein spiel mit dem feuer wenn man das
parteitaktischen gründen hier zu keiner
einigung kommen
ihm geht es um das ansehen des
parlaments deshalb wie sie auch bis
zuletzt immer wieder auf die gerade in
zeiten der pandemie unverzichtbare
parlamentsrechte ihn und er forderte sie
selbstbewusst wahrzunehmen
thomas oppermann zitiere gern den großen
aufklärer georg friedrich lichtenberg
ich kann ich sagen ob es besser werden
wird wenn es anders wird
aber so viel kann ich sagen das muss
anders werden wenn es gut werden soll
er selbst engagierte sich dafür dass sie
sind unsere gesellschaft gerecht und
fair zugeht
das ist gut wird thomas oppermann liebte
das leben die kultur das lesen
den sport und wer ihn zuletzt traf
spürte dass er mit sich im reinen war
und voller vorfreude auf die zeit nach
der aktiven politik seien eher droht
durchkreuzte diese pläne auf tragische
weise
und so nehmen wir abschied von einem
leidenschaftlichen sozialdemokraten und
parlamentarier einem erfahrenen
politiker der unser land in den
vergangenen jahrzehnten in
herausragenden ämtern mitgestaltet hat
thomas oppermann hat sich um den
parlamentarismus und die demokratie in
unserem land große verdienste erworben
der deutsche bundestag wird ihm ein
ehrendes andenken bewahren
[Musik]
liebe frau kirchhoff liebe familie von
thomas oppermann
sehr geehrter herr bundestagspräsident
sehr geehrte frau bundeskanzlerin sehr
geehrter herr bundespräsident lieber
herr bundeskanzler wie bewerb
weggefährten liebe kolleginnen liebe
kollegen wenn wir vom tod eines
nahestehenden menschen erfahren fühlt es
sich an als würde die zeit einfrieren
so erging es uns die nachricht dass
thomas oppermann am sonntag abend
verstorben ist war ein schock
mit ihm verlieren wir einen angesehenen
sozialdemokraten einen
leidenschaftlichen abgeordneten und eine
bedeutende politische persönlichkeit die
vielen reaktionen zeigen thomas
oppermann hatte eine strahlkraft in ganz
unterschiedliche bevölkerungsgruppen
hinein
er war ein stratege ein gestalter ein
energiebündel ein feiner kerl
er wird uns fehlen 30 jahre lang war
thomas oppermann parlamentarischer sechs
sicher landtagsabgeordnete und dann
wissenschaftsminister seit 2005
bundestagsabgeordneter erster
parlamentarischer geschäftsführer
fraktionsvorsitzender vizepräsident
seinen erfolg verdankt er nicht zuletzt
seinen geschliffenen formulierungen
einer professionellen arbeitsweise und
den analytischen fähigkeiten des
gelernten juristen ob der mann war ein
generalist im besten sinne der zu fast
allen politischen themen fundiert sprech
fähig war
er beherrschte in der tat die abteilung
klartext und attacke genauso wie
staatstragende auftritte besonders
eindrucksvoll war es wie ihr das amt des
ersten pdf neue definierten
bundespräsident frank walter steinmeier
zu zitieren
thomas oppermann hat die aufgaben des
ersten parlamentarischen
geschäftsführers mit seiner
handschriftlich vorbildlich ja
beispielgebend geprägt es ist kein
geheimnis thomas oppermann wäre gern
bundesminister geworden
dieser unerfüllte wunsch hielt ihn
jedoch nicht davon ab die rolle des
abgeordneten mit leib und seele
auszufüllen für ihn war der bundestag
eine selbstbewusste institution mit
einer ganz eigenen bedeutung und das
sogenannte struck gesetz in stein für
ihn gemeißelt kein gesetzentwurf der
regierung verlässt dieses haus so wie es
hineingekommen ist er verstandes
unterschiedliche meinungen
zusammenzuführen und faire kompromisse
auszuhandeln
der politische einfluss war für ihn kein
selbstzweck sein einsatz ergab sich
vielmehr aus dem gestaltungswillen mehr
lebenschancen für mehr menschen zu
schaffen
ein leitmotiv war dass sich soziale
gerechtigkeit und wirtschaftliche
dynamik nicht ausschließen sondern sich
gegenseitig bedingen und ergänzen
ob man schritt für einen starken
vorsorgenden sozialstaat der menschen
nach möglichkeit nicht dauerhaft
versorgt sondern ihnen hilft auf eigenen
füßen zu stehen
zugleich hat er immer ein offenes ohr
für die wirtschaft schließlich sei die
spd auch von handwerkern und kleinen
selbstständigen gegründet worden sagte
er
und er machte politik für die leute die
hart arbeiten und sich an die regeln
halten
als sohn eines molkerei meisters der
einen kleinen betrieb führte wusste er
wovon er sprach
1976 gegen thomas oppermann der
bundestagspräsident sie haben es erwähnt
mit der aktion sühnezeichen für zwei
jahre in die usa wie die gelegenheit
hatte darüber mit ihm zu sprechen weiß
dass diese arbeit einen tiefgehenden
eindruck hinterlassen hatte er
organisierte proteste gegen
mieterhöhungen und boykottaktionen der
landarbeiter gewerkt
die sich gegen schlechte
arbeitsbedingungen werte später schrieb
er über diese zeit ich hatte gelernt
dass sich soziale gerechtigkeit nicht
von selbst einstellt sondern immer das
ergebnis politischer einmischung ist
zurück in deutschland wechselte
oppermann das fach und begann die hurra
zu studieren er wollte sich auch bei uns
in die politik einbringen für mehr
gerechtigkeit und die soziale demokratie
der engagierte sich in der
hochschulpolitik und bei der
mieterberatung wurde verwaltungsrichter
und schließlich abgeordneter seine tiefe
verbundenheit zu den vereinigten staaten
blieb bestehen thomas oppermann war
überzeugter transatlantiker und reiste
regelmäßig in die usa
für ihn stand fest eine lebendige
demokratie braucht die beteiligung der
bürgerinnen und bürger aber auch ihr
vertrauen in die staatliche
handlungsfähigkeit um freiheit und
demokratie zu erhalten so oppermann sei
es nötig öffentliche wie soziale
sicherheit herzustellen und so das
vertrauen in den staat in den staat und
seine schutzfunktion zu stärken
das ist der grund weshalb thomas
oppermann sich für das thema innere
sicherheit und ordnung einsetzte und als
fraktionsvorsitzender metall deutlich
mehr stellen bei der bundespolizei zu
schaffen den entwurf eines modernen
einwanderungsgesetz
der quasi im alleingang klare
rechtsstaatliche verfahren und regeln
dafür trage er auch als vizepräsident 1
in einem artikel über den ehemaligen
reichstags präsidenten paul löbe
formulierte er im parlament soll schafe
inhaltliche kritik erlaubt die
verachtung der parlamentarischen arbeit
dagegen nicht
und weiter deshalb war beim einzug zitat
der afc in den bundestag richtig von
anfang an unmissverständlich auf die
einhaltung der regeln zu pochen
das heißt jede form der obstruktion
schon im ansatz zu unterbinden ohne die
chancen einer demokratisch gewählten
partei zu beeinträchtigen sind es thomas
oppermann schuldig dass diese gesetze
diese sätze auch in zukunft gültigkeit
besitzen
thomas oppermann war ein großer freund
israels ohne wenn und aber trat er für
das existenzrecht des staates ein und
die deutsch-israelische ausübung in
einer grundsatzrede sagte er es gibt in
der beziehung zu israel keine normalität
in dem sinne dass sie durch einen
schlussstrich unter die vergangenheit
begründet werden könnte die
vergangenheit hat konsequenzen bis heute
und auch in der zukunft
thomas oppermann hat sich um unser land
und unsere demokratie verdient gemacht
wer ihn näher kannte weiß dass thomas
oppermann nicht nur ein herausragender
politiker war er war auch ein
vielseitiger und belesener mensch mit
dem es nie langweilig wurde diskutierte
gern
er sprühte nur so vor ideen und hatte
einen ausgeprägten sinn für humor
er begeisterte sich für kunst und kultur
und er liebte den sport seine
wandergruppe war ihm wichtig er spielte
fußball beim fc bundestag
und er war ein begeisterter basketball
fan thomas oppermann hatte vor zwei
monaten angekündigt bei der nächsten
bundestagswahl nicht wieder zu
kandidieren sein plan war in der ihm
eigenen art noch einmal etwas ganz neues
anzufangen
dazu kommt es nun nicht mehr das
schmerzt und stimmen uns unheimlich
traurig klar ist aber auch wir werden
ihnen sehr guter erinnerung behalten was
er angestoßen und aufgebaut hat werden
wir weiterführen
er wird in unseren herzen und taten
weiterleben wir sind in unseren gedanken
bei seinen angehörigen wir trauern mit
ihnen und wünschen ihnen kraft und
zuversicht
gleichzeitig sind wir dankbar dass wir
einen teil unseres weges zusammen mit
thomas gehen durften seit an
von let it be mit denen paul mccartney 1
den tod seiner eigenen mutter
verarbeitet hat endet die trauerfeier
für thomas oppermann den
bundestagsvizepräsidenten und
langjährigen spd abgeordneten im plenum
des deutschen bundestages eben beisein
seiner lebensgefährtin und von drei
seiner vier kinder haben wolfgang
schäuble der bundestagspräsident und
rolf mützenich der fraktionschef der spd
sein lebenswerk sein politisches
schaffen der letzten drei jahrzehnte
gewürdigt
auf der besuchertribüne auch der
ehemalige bundespräsident gauck der
ehemalige spd-chef sigmar gabriel andrea
nahles viele andere die jetzt noch
einmal innehalten und wohl jeder
persönlich an die zeit zurückdenken wird
die ihn oder sie mit thomas oppermann
verbindet 66 jahre alt ist er nur
geworden am sonntagabend plötzlich und
unerwartet verstorben
tja diese andächtige nachdenkliche
atmosphäre wird nun dem
parlamentarischen alltag jedoch